Lindsay I am so devastated that you were
sent off because you were my favorite
player this season I'm not even just
saying that I was like immediately from
episode one I was like I love Lindsay I
think she's gonna make it so far you're
such a Powerhouse I know and so last
night or two nights ago I was like
yelling at my TV I was like no no I
didn't see it coming but you know let's
talk about that Blind Side because not
only for viewers it was obviously a
blind side for you
um what was going through your head as
Jeff was reading those votes at Tribal
Council I knew it was me going home that
night unfortunately
um but it's still sad I mean after
22 years of wanting to play this game
and I was actually supposed to play on
season 42 and 12 hours before I was
supposed to fly uh to LA to then go to
Fiji I got covered and so this was just
I don't think anybody can really wrap
their heads around like what 22 years of
wanting to do something means and
um when you want to do something for 22
years you have 22 years of time to to
have these expectations for yourself
right
um and in the meantime here I am trying
to figure out okay when I first wanted
to play I was young and 20 years old but
now I'm 42 and and what does it look
like for a woman that's 42 to play this
game right
um I was the oldest woman on my tribe I
was so concerned about coming off as a
liability I wanted to be a huge asset
around camp and challenges
um socially I wasn't concerned I feel
like I'm a very social player but um I
wanted to make sure that my tribe found
me valuable I think my issue was is I
was trying to find that balance of my
tribe finding value on me but also
flying under the radar which like
clearly is not something that I'm able
to do out there so so do you think
because you know you were great at
puzzles and like even the physical stuff
which is obviously challenging the
longer that you're in there oh no
problem you were amazing every time
you're on a puzzle I was like yes yes
um
puzzle Queen
um so do you think that contributed to
what happened on Wednesday night yes
absolutely and and I say that because
um I also want to give my other trimates
um a credit for for taking me out
um nobody gets voted out for being
paranoid for just a couple of hours
um and if they do then then shame on me
but it's also like shame on them because
I was a loyal uh tribe and Alliance
member to them
um it was just a reason for Carla to be
able to say it's it's time for Lindsay
to go Carla was definitely concerned
um when Carly was playing both sides you
know she she had Ryan and Geo on one
side and James was kind of a part of
that
um but she was also playing us and there
were a lot of lies going on and and it
was things were starting to get messy
and it was starting to get really hard
for Carla uh to remember who she was
telling what to what stories she was
telling and when she saw Geo and I
speaking on the beach that day and she
found out that Geo had told me that my
name was being thrown out there that's
where my paranoia came from Geo told me
hey Ryan's throwing your name out there
Ryan's saying you're a threat in this
game and that you've got to go home
tonight after nine days of them saying
that Cassidy was going to be their vote
Carla's seeing Geo and I talking Carla
sees Geo giving me information and she's
like
oh gosh I'm about my game's about to get
blown up I've got to take somebody out
and it's got to be Lindsay
so do was that the moment or was there
another moment at camp that made you
realize okay I'm the one who's most
likely going to be going home tonight
um me getting paranoid did not help uh
there were definitely a few red flags
leading up to
um tribal council that made me very
nervous
um Carla normally Carla will always talk
to me Carla and I were always going off
and chatting and talking strategy and
there was a moment where I said hey
Carla like let's let's go off and talk
and and she refused to talk to me and
and I thought oh gosh like there's a red
flag and then
um in a Carla aggressive tone she looked
at me and said like you're not playing
your shot in the dark tonight are you
almost as in like if I do it's gonna
blow up her game as opposed to saying
like Lance don't waste your shot in the
dark it's not you you know which is
again the conversations that we had been
having so I definitely felt a little
tension there
um I was concerned with James I I wasn't
necessarily sure that he was telling me
the truth about
um when he went on the journey you know
he said he didn't risk his vote but I
didn't necessarily believe that and when
Cody came to radar Camp I brought up
that Journey just to see how James would
react and what information Cody had and
James kind of he kind of tensed up and
he got a little weird and he wasn't
participating in that conversation and
he was kind of shutting it down so again
all of us girls thought well that's a
little weird right if he's got nothing
to hide then like why is he acting so
weird in this conversation
um so so there were definitely a lot of
red flags that led to my paranoia it
wasn't like I was just fine fine fine
for nine days not not even worrying
about it and then all of a sudden you
know I just I flip and and I get
paranoid for no reason yeah absolutely
now after all of that transpired is
there someone specifically that you feel
the most betrayed by like in your
alliance
coming out of the game I felt incredibly
betrayed by James my heart was
absolutely broken I mean you guys don't
see it but James and I had some really
incredible conversations about
um just working in healthcare and and
what it was like for me as a nurse to
take care of coveted patients I I talked
to them about
um about I was supposed to play on
season 42 and and I wasn't able to play
and
I talked to them about that we had some
really special conversations out there
um and James isn't getting enough credit
for his social gameplay uh all of us
girls thought that we were James's
number one and so I I was really sad
about that
um I I was sad about Carla it took a lot
for me to be able to get past like what
she had done to me
um I didn't necessarily
feel that Cassidy betrayed me in the way
that Carla and James did I know Cassidy
didn't want me to go out but you get
hurt you're out there for nine days and
you create this family and you're so
loyal to them and then all of a sudden
they turn on you it it hurts you because
you're like how is it that they don't
find me valuable enough to keep around
especially when we had talked for nine
days about getting Geo out so absolutely
and yeah absolutely and even when you
like left you didn't say a word to
anyone what was going through your head
and like as you were leaving
so because Geo told me that Ryan was
coming after me and that I was the vote
that night and it was because I was a
threat I honestly in that moment
believed that everybody was working
behind my back that wasn't necessarily
the case right at the time I felt like
when I was having those conversations
with Carla and James that they were
gaslighting me like Lindsay you're being
paranoid for no reason and I'm saying to
them I'm not being paranoid for no
reason I was just told my name's being
thrown out you guys aren't being told
your name's being thrown out Cassidy
unfortunately was on a walk that day and
so I wasn't able to have these
conversations with her otherwise Cassidy
would be thrown in this mix too
unfortunately Cassidy was off doing a
confessional and so
um I wasn't able to like throw these
ideas by her I'm almost curious as to
how things would be different if I had
had Cassie my closest Alliance member
there with me to either calm me down or
talk me through it or help me understand
like what was really going on so I'm
really sad that she wasn't there
I love hearing all of this like stuff
you don't see on TV I find it so
fascinating as a Survivor fan
right yeah um let's Circle back to the
immunity challenge okay yeah we'll do
the immunity Challenge and then we'll
talk a little bit about reward but
immunity like when you notice that you
know these two tribes are working kind
of like helping each other because they
pretty much want to send you guys to
Tribal Council you guys hired the full
six like you have a full tribe like is
that stressful watching it and seeing it
all unfold
so uh I didn't realize it until Jeff
told us after the challenge was over
um looking back and watching the episode
James saw it happening
um in Cassidy and Geo saw it happening
too but
when it comes like I don't think anybody
realized this I hate losing like it is a
toxic creative mind like I despise it
and so I get so competitive in that
moment I was also incredibly frustrated
that I wasn't able to do the puzzle
myself
um so I just wanted to make sure that I
was helping and supporting Carla and
Ryan do the puzzle
um what you guys don't see is there was
a moment where
um
we thought we had solved the puzzle
correctly and so we're all celebrating
and streaming and high-fiving and
hugging each other and just like no
that's not it oh my gosh and so we go
into panic mode and have to go back into
the puzzle and at that moment that's
when they start helping each other
um another thing that you guys don't see
is in the challenge beforehand when they
had to choose who was going to go on the
journey
um it was the journey with James and
Noel
um Dwight asked Baca to send Noel
and so when Dwight when Noel were
helping Baca solve that puzzle that was
their way of saying hey you had our
backs last time like we're gonna do you
a solid and and pay you back for that
favor and that's why Dwight and Noel
ended up helping Baca oh wow I love this
tea I love this sorority I love hearing
all this stuff yeah um and then quickly
going to the reward Challenge and then
you know you have Cody come to your camp
like obviously it's kind of
unprecedented like you don't know what's
gonna happen and he's kind of bartering
and seeing what he can get out of you
guys did you guys have a strategy if
they were going to come to your camp and
then when he did like what happened was
it just chaos
it wasn't necessarily chaos Cody's
mentality
um and I think he stayed
um pretty loyal to like this mentality
of um I'm just here to have fun and you
know just like a surfer bro from Hawaii
and Dwight's calling the shots at our
camp and he's The Mastermind and I'm
just listening to what he's telling me
to do
um My Tribe told me to take your machete
they want to you know cut you guys off
but hey I'm just a peacemaker and I'm
not trying to piss anybody off and and
tell you what why don't I just do you
guys a solid my tribe is going to be
super mad at me when I get back but like
why don't I just take your fishing gear
and I'll be the first to admit like I am
a terrible negotiator like I am horrible
at it right
um I'm good at a lot of things but it is
not that so um I was just like here take
everything whatever you want as long as
you don't take my machete I didn't
realize
um some of our tribe mates were a little
annoyed by uh what Cody was able to get
away with but
um after seeing them working together
and knowing that they were coming for us
I was just so grateful that they didn't
take the things that we needed most
absolutely now just to kind of wrap up
your journey on Survivor seeing it all
unfold on Wednesday night how are you
feeling now and is this Survivor Journey
everything that you hoped it would be
it absolutely is not everything that I
hoped it would be I've got so much more
gain left in me I I felt like
um it ended way too soon but of course
I'm gonna say that like I I obviously
have like this Survivor bucket list of
all these things that I wanted to
accomplish
but I'm the type of person that believes
that like everything happens for a
reason right so if everything happens
for a reason then like I have to believe
that this happened for a reason as well
and maybe I don't understand what it is
exactly like just yet I will at some
point and and I'm trying to be open to
that
um but I'm sad my journey was was cut
too soon I my nine days out there I got
everything out of that game that I
wanted to
um in terms of
um surviving and and living off the
island and and proving to myself I
didn't have anything to prove to anybody
else like
in my everyday life like you know I'm a
nurse I'm a great mom I'm a great friend
like I I I just took care of covet
patients for a couple of years like I
didn't need to be to go out there to
learn like how tough and strong I was
what I wanted was to be able to have the
experience like I said in my in my
pre-game interview I was so scared of
just never being able to play so to go
out there and have the time of my life
and not have to go to tribal for nine
days and and not be paranoid and and
worried just to go out there and have a
blast was just the greatest gift in the
world and I'm so grateful for it well
that's a great outlook on everything
despite it not necessarily playing out
the way you wanted but I would be
totally down for you to come on the show
again I loved watching you so I feel
like we need to get another season of
people who were voted off before jury
that you know make it happen but it was
lovely chatting with you
um I'm so sorry and the way it did but
again I loved watching you so thank you
so much I appreciate it thank you so so
much for your love and support